longtime friend
and a longtime caller and he's back here
on the rich eisen show lots to discuss
after a super wild card weekend with one
more game coming up on monday night
football nfl
rules analyst for fox sports and then of
course uh former head of nfl officials
mike pereira back here on the rich eisen
show how you doing mike
i'm doing great rich let's jump in it uh
with both feet starting with the end of
the cowboys 49ers game did you have a
problem with the mechanics the way it
all went down
at the end of the game on sunday
a little bit um you know it's
interesting i flew from tampa to dallas
and uh landed in dallas with troy and
our producer richie ziontin we got the
game on our phone it was the last minute
that's really all we saw the game was
the last minute and we were looking at
this thing oh the 49ers fourth and one
the measurement oh they're short now
they're going to go for it then they
didn't get set and then it goes to the
last play and we're all we're watching
this on a phone in the airplane and
we're going oh well oh what whoa what is
it over we're like everybody else you
know watching it and
you know obviously that's been the
discussion point today and
i think the thing is to me look at
people are saying that the umpire and
the referee were so far back ruben
george is the empire and
you know they line up 15 yards behind
the line of scrimmage and when back
steps back they stepped back and so they
had a long way to go and so
i i think they worked their butts off to
get to the spot
really though to me and we have
discussed this before
the one thing when you're in such a
hurry up like that don't worry about a
yard putting the ball back i mean he
could see that the line of scrimmage
guys on the outside had a spot on the
solid line
but just touch the ball and get out of
there and if you want to adjust it if
there's still time left on the clock
then you can put it back a yard um but
it when they're gonna when they look at
this that's what they're gonna say hey
if this scenario hits again you've got
to touch the ball okay and it's hard you
got to go through players that are
already in
three-point stances and ready to go but
you've got to touch the ball touch it
and get out don't worry about moving it
back to yard because
i mean that's hardly relevant at this
point at that point of time anyways but
you know it's very interesting to watch
the last minute of the game and then
listen to the post game comments by the
announcer babe waffenburg who didn't
talk at all about the umpire getting the
ball he talked more about the 14
penalties that the cowboys committed in
and he said they earned every one of
them except one maybe a little iffy and
he talked about them being undisciplined
and
i have a hard time putting
that last play where maybe they would
have gotten a play off i i have a hard
time putting the total focus of the
cowboys lost on that but that being said
i i think mechanically it could have
been handled a little bit better so your
so the two cents uh would be one in the
same way that dak would have homework
and the cowboys would have homework to
drill into dak if he needs it
uh to find the official that you know to
find the official to give the football
to the official to spot don't give it to
your center spot in the same way you
would tell
the umpire just
just touch it get out of the way they're
going to spike it anyway then you
re-spot the ball
before the end of the game that would be
the the homework for the ump and i must
tell you
and i thought about this last night in
some ways i accept part of the blame on
this okay because if you go back to 2009
after the 2009 season before i left in
2010 i'm the one that pushed for the
change the mechanics change to move the
umpire into the offensive backfield
and i knew that it created a hole um i
recognized that but i was more
interested in umpire safety because i
was losing two a year they were getting
killed they were getting used as picks
so i said let's move him to the
offensive side i think if he'd have been
in his old spot he would have gotten
there quicker and um and
and that was a concern and and we at
that point said hey if it's a ball down
field and the back judge can get to the
ball do it but it's still the umpire's
primary responsibility and
it is one of those situational um things
that come up that probably that
mechanics changed kept the umpire from
getting obviously was lined up behind
the linebackers he would have probably
gone right with the team down there and
would have been there quicker but um so
i guess i accept some of the blame for
that fox rules analyst mike pereira
former head of nfl refs right here on
the rich eisen show let's get to the
game uh in cincinnati this was a huge
conversation for much of the day
saturday and it's gotten knocked off
of a lot of
twitter exchanges because of what
happened
in dallas but the whistle being blown as
joe burrow let loose with a touchdown
pass because i guess
the official thought that burrow was out
of bounds the whistle clearly hit
uh clearly uh sounded before uh the ball
hit taj boyd's
hands in the end zone
what is your opinion of that sequence
from that well my opinion is that i'm
really pretty disappointed and and
actually very concerned and and i did
express those sentiments to the league
um because basically what they attempted
to do
and what they ended up doing
was ignore the ruling that was made
initially on the field that that borough
stepped out of bounds that was the
ruling that was made
and yet he didn't i get that he didn't
so then
and the claim is they tried to do this
on the field all their own the claim is
then they tried to factor in when the
whistle blew
we've never gotten to that point where
either on the field or in replay that
you try to factor in where the when the
whistle blew i mean you you basically
especially in replay you try to ignore
that element the ruling kills the play
and there are even case book plays that
say if the runners ruled the passer is
ruled out of bounds it's not reviewable
you can't go back and review that yet we
had a play
um i think it was last year with buffalo
same same scenario that it was ruled
that
the quarterback was out of bounds and
they let it be challenged and they
actually overturned it when it wasn't
reviewable and i went nuts in that
scenario too but the feeling was well
let's try to correct everything let's
try to correct everything and that's
what i my voice to the league i'm i'm
concerned that you're using this video
assistant expedited review too far to
get involved in place that take you into
trying to determine when did a whistle
blow i mean that's that's like that's
like almost impossible to do and you
look at it on tv and yeah it blew
right before the catch was made yes
but again
were ignoring the ruling that was made
on the field and i mean i said to him if
they if you rule that a runner steps out
of bounds at the 10-yard line and he
didn't
you say it's not reviewable you can't do
anything about it because it was ruled
dead and so i
i'm not i i'm i'm frustrated by that
play okay maybe
they got it right maybe they did but i
still think the whistle blew before the
ball was actually caught but i just
don't think we should have ever gotten
to that point we cannot set aside
a rule
to try to get the play right and that
that's that's where i feel we're headed
and that's no secret i mean i voiced it
to the league i just
that that's it's concerning to me it's
very concerning to me that we're trying
to
go too far to try to get the field
call right on the field when i know
they're in contact with everybody
they're in contact with the replay
official that could say to them hey he
didn't step out of bounds well they said
well they made this whole decision on
the field
it makes it very suspicious and i look
at that play if it was me
back in my day yes i said well we ruled
he was out of bounds when he threw the
past that's it it's over
you can't do anything about that so
basically what you're saying is again uh
the place should have been blown dead
the minute that they thought that he had
stepped out of bounds and that is not
reviewable
right because he had three right so
the whistle correct and so
so they they they inappropriately
used replay
to keep a a possibility of a touchdown
alive that they should have replayed
anyway
right because of the whistle on the air
is that what you're saying
well they said they made the decision
completely on the field without the use
of i don't know i have a hard time
buying that um it wasn't a replay review
um because
essentially and i didn't watch it so i
couldn't see
you know the actions of
jerome bulger i i don't know how long it
took to get to the thing but it's still
it's it's really bothersome to me i like
this expedited review i do i like the
video assistance i do
but i don't like it when it brings in
elements of the game where
you know even replay if it went to
replay wouldn't allow you to review it
so i i'm
you know i don't i really i don't know
the word to use rich i mean i i think
i'm disappointed maybe disillusioned
um but i just i think they they've gone
too far to end up trying to determine
when did a whistle blow on the field and
and trying to make that determination
you know based on when a ball was first
touched and so you make a decision and
then it turns out it was wrong because
the whistle was before the ball was
touched
it's
it's confusing to a lot of people mike i
gotta be honest this is a confu this is
confusing because you know the
conversation is they should have
replayed the down because the whistle
was inadvertent and that is the rule i
don't believe that i know what john
perry said i know what others said the
fact is that the whistle blew because
the official
felt that the that the player was out of
bounds
on the line and um and that's why it
blew i don't call that inadvertent i
call that killing the play because you
had a ruling on the field of him being
down out of bounds so i don't buy the
the inadvertent whistle it was blown for
a reason and that when that the net was
blown before the the whistle was blown
because you felt that the runner stepped
out of bounds that's it
and you and you to me you have to stay
with that ruling
it's incredible so instead of it being
replayed because of an inadvertent
whistle the the whistle was not
inadvertent and actually blew a play
dead that's not reviewable that they
went ahead and reviewed and and
installed the touchdown
very simple to me the next place should
have been cincinnati's ball from the
from the spot where burroughs was ruled
to have stepped out of bounds period
that's neat and so uh a couple more for
you mike pereira uh right here on the
rich eisen show uh on sunday night
football you know the game was kind of
out of reach but steelers fans are are
wondering uh nick allegretti the big man
who scored a touchdown uh last night
threw tj watt to the ground before going
out on his route um and there was no
call is that is that legal for i guess
an eligible
tackle to just throw
someone to the ground normally that
would be a hold because he's a he is uh
an ineligible receiver it could be a
whole could be offensive pass
interference but if it occurs at the
line of scrimmage it can't be offensive
past interference but i'd like to be
more knowledgeable on that but i just
didn't see it okay yeah i saw a
highlight of him catching the past but
did not i did not see him release from
the line of scrimmage yes he threw he
threw the diff you know would be
defensive player of the year to the
ground like a rag doll before being wide
open because tj what was on the ground
and
it was right around the line it was tj
trying to rush the passer you know was
he was he trying to contact you know i
think tj tj got up with the uh with the
international symbol of where's the flag
uh and his hands outstretched which made
it seem like he thought he was being
engaged by a blocking tackle and was
thrown to the ground and then turned
around and saw the tackle catch
the ball for the touchdown so if he says
i'm an eligible receiver and is deemed
as such and this is all within the line
of scrimmage
uh vicinity that's legal to throw him
down on the ground is what you're saying
it's legal in terms of offensive pass
interference because in order for her to
have an interference ballot has to be
more than a yard down field but i would
have to see the play to see if if watt
was trying to go through a gap or trying
to get uh into the backfield i'd have to
i'd have to see that because it's much
like a screen you know if if they you
know a lineman who wants to get out on
the screen if he throws
a player to the ground a defender to the
ground then that is holding um
and it could be the same scenario
in this case but um i know the only one
thing i can say is it could not have
been past interference all right and uh
last one for you just going back to the
end of the cowboys 49ers game the uh the
head ref um said afterwards that they
did not
converse with new york city as to
whether
there was no time left on the clock in
regulation made that ruling themselves
and got off the field
um
would you would you you're laughing
already so uh lingo standard lingo for
what um
you know
and they may have done that look the
first thing i looked at is when i was
huddled around troy's phone was how much
time could have been left on the clock
when he spiked it you know because if
there's if they deem that the play that
the game is over and you look at it and
the ball hits the ground with one second
to go not reviewable there has to be two
seconds or more on the clock or replay
to put time those two seconds or more
back on the clock and i don't think
there was even one second um but i i
promise you that because that actually
is reviewable they may not have
conversed with new york but they would
have conversed to the replay official to
before they left the field to make sure
that the time had expired no
conversation about the mechanics of
putting the ball down or that but
replay is
responsible for making sure there is not
two or more seconds left on the clock
and if there's not then the game is over
so i'm sure that was the conversation
and you have no problem with the game
being ruled over then
no okay
mike pereira thank you for the time
let's do this again down the line we'll
see you soon
you got it take care there is former
henna fl nfl vp of officiating and fox
sports nfl rules analyst mike pereira
here in the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here